はじめん
まさかのまだおきてたりは？
おきてますよ。
こんばんは。Dｒ.はじめです。
ネットのニュースんちょびっと話題になってたものがあります。
あっ！
セイキンさんが2週間前にやってますね。
ネタがかぶってしまいました。
ヤります。
悪夢を見るチーズ、というものが売っていたので、　　買ってみました。
こちら、ちょっと買ってみました。
(これも)中古屋さんで見つけたんで買ってきました。
かわいいでしょ?
これですね。
この中に悪夢のチーズが入ってます。
Ho~!
怖いよー。
でも、普通に食べ物でしょ?
賞味期限は3月までもつみたいです。
Year.
なんでこれが悪夢を見るって言われてんだろう?
面白半分でやるより、なんでそういうことを言われるか調べてみましょう。
有名なんですね。
"スティルトン"
え? すご!
えーとー
これ1個で大体120グラムなんで...
6分の1食べればいいのかな。
うお、凄い!
公式が発表してる、チーズ委員会みたいなやつがー
4時44分だ、今!
不吉や~
お酒と合うみたいですね。
怖い!
でも、やってみたい!!!
というわけでやります。
パッと見は、ただのチーズなんすよね。
チーズって腐ってるんすよね。
チーズがなんだかよく分かんないからな。
匂い......
あ、普通にいい匂いのチーズだ、これ、多分
怖いよ、ママー!
では、早速、スティルトンチーズを食べていこうと　　思います。
いや...
20グラムなんて、
少ないよな。
俺はもっとこう...
たまんねぇくらいの悪夢、見たいと思ってるんで
1個食えたら一番いいんですけど。
どれだけ食えるかは、
オレ次第。
チーズ1個食うのってなかなかきついと思うんだよな。
試しに食べてみますわ。いただきます。
うまっ!
おえっ!
助けてー。悪夢やー。
チーズって腐ってるんだっけ?
なんか、腐って...
おえー!
ビールうめー!
ちょびっとクラッカーに乗せるぐらいで美味いやつ　　だわ。
これぐらい。
ちょっと乗せるぐらいでいいんすよね。
うめー、大人の味わいだ。
単品で食うと...言い方悪くすると、
クソまずかったんですけど。
クラッカーと混ぜると、めっちゃくちゃおいしいです。めっちゃ合う。
寝る30分前に食べなきゃいけないんで、
ボクはこれを食いしだい、早々に寝ます。
チーズとお酒って、
合うね!
ね!
ごめん、もう無理。
ただ、20グラム以上は確実に食っております。
半分は
行ったかな、分かんないですけど
結構、食ったと思います!!!
悪夢を見るかどうかはよくわかんないすけど、
普通に　美味しかったっす
酒が。
あと、クラッカー。
では、寝ます。
このまま30分以内に寝るって書いてあったんで、すぐ寝て、
起きてからのボクの夢の感想と、
寝てる間に僕の体に異変はないかも含めて、
撮っていこうと思います。おやすみなさい!
悪夢のチーズを食べてから30分以内なので、
今から寝ると、奇妙な夢を見るということで、
早速寝ていこうと思います。おやすみなさい。
はい、おはようございます。
あのー、
頭いてー。
ビール飲んだから頭いてぇーや
結果から言いますと、
本当に、
奇妙な夢を見ました
なんか夢ってさー、あれなんすよねー
なんか曖昧だから、
具体的なことまでは覚えてないんですけど、
とりあえず
マジで奇妙な夢だった気がします。
それで、とりあえず、あのー
で、すごい...
楽しかった夢でした。